Northern Pakistan is home to some of the
world's highest mountain peaks it is
rugged territory with little land for
cultivation environmental experts a
warning of a Potential Threat because of
climate change especially here in
Pakistan the Creations are so huge the
phenomenon is so important that the
quantity of water which is
being produced by the melting
certainly creates
unwanted effects such as floating
landslides which affect the population
besides tourism pakistanis have to carve
out a living Often by growing cherries
and apricots watered by plentiful supply
of fresh water from the melting glaciers
they also provide a Lifeline for
everyone and bring fertile soil for
cultivation the glaciers also act as
joint minerals to reflect solar heat to
help keep the Earth cool
because of climate change the Glaciers
are melting at an unprecedented raid and
that means dangerous floods and water
shortages for tens of millions of people
across Pakistan
for many here climate change is an
existential threat the village of
hosseini is in the direct part of a
nearby Glacier and its inhabitants ready
it may wipe out everything
the glacier was far away but has moved
closer and we fear it may burst what
will we do we don't have any other place
to go to we have already lost hundreds
of trees and crops and chunks of our
land has been swept away at night we
hear loud sounds from the glacier and
it's scary
glaciers like this and others around the
world have already shrunk and many more
may be gone entirely soon the question
is will countries around the world take
the threat seriously and act to cut
greenhouse gas emissions
or look the other way while the last
remaining glaciers in these mountains
disappear Kamal Hyder Al Jazeera gilgat
baltistan
foreign